we are back with our exclusive
appearance on television for the very
first time together the greatest amy and
david sedaris
and
they are going to cook
their mom's pasta recipe and i got so
excited to honor your mom
and amy you're in the driver's seat
please teach us okay this is called
greek spaghetti and everyone used to
always laugh when you say greek
spaghetti and they're like what is greek
spaghetti like we made it up but the
reason it's greek spaghetti is you
actually brown a stick of butter and you
add it to the sauce i mean that's what
makes it greek i must say yeah and
usually serve it with um chela salvage
chicken which is just um greek chicken
oregano and lemon olive oil or pork
chops meatballs so you want like some
kind of meat on the side i love a telly
cevalus
when that came out in bone appetit in
the 80s my family were like devoured it
so we cooked a lot of telly savalas
recipes i love it we loved him so what
you're going to do is you're going to
take a pan you're going to put some
olive oil in it and you're going to put
onion in it you're going to put a
chicken bouillon cube in it i put two
you put two
david makes this really well the best in
the family um i love a bullion cube and
the pasta that's a first i haven't seen
that yeah and then if your friends are
vegetarian you still do it you just say
you didn't do it right yeah exactly
all right then when that's all simmered
first of all david's adds crushed red
pepper to his i like it because
just a little you want to put that in
there and then touch your eyes and then
i'm going to laugh
my nose stick your nose and then you're
going to add i believe this is oregano
so you put as much oregano in there all
of it wow
and then some parsley
okay so you're just gonna stir that up
then you're gonna add
one or two cans of crushed
um tomatoes you pour the tomato sauce
your can of tomatoes into this pot over
here so right that's the finished
product so in there you're going to add
the lid yes put the lid in and then pour
the sauce over the perfect okay perfect
i'm sure if anyone can eat around that
that's perfect
wow that's fun
okay then
the thing another thing that makes a
greek is you're going to take the
parmesan cheese and you're going to add
it to the to the sauce now here's the
question when do we add the butter we
put the sauce on the spaghetti we mix it
up and then we add okay so sauce first
butter second yeah so there you go and
david i'll let you mix that and the
butter has to be brown right like just
when you think it's ready give it
another few seconds yeah and piping you
know and it's tricky you know with
butter you have to keep your eye on it i
burn mine all the time now you're going
to take the brown butter and you're
going to pour it on top of the spaghetti
and you're going to mix it again again
yes i did that i'm okay i'm all mixed
together really doing a great job mixing
it thank you and that's pretty much
greek spaghetti and then this feta is
beautiful i don't know
uh
what kind of fat it is it looks so good
and then you can serve it like i said
with telly's vows chicken or pork chops
meatballs or just plain
it's really good it's a crowd pleaser um
alice and alicia will you start and try
it oh my god look at her look at how she
did
it's not going perfectly
i'm pretty impressed for someone who put
a lid in their sauce
i know right
wow oh my god
and then i can crumble a little feta on
there just on the side if you don't want
to crumble it because now your hands are
going to smell like spoiled rotten milk
that's okay i'll lick those fingers i
love a good feta and then i always find
that a garnish makes a huge difference
like if you want to feel like you were
at a restaurant and that gives it a
punch a color like paprika or something
on a baked potato and then look at that
perfect there we go
[Applause]
um okay hold on
[Applause]
i made that beautiful
how is it oh my god did you do it right
oh my god
i'll be the judge oh my god amy this is
absolutely delicious what do you think
it's like good home old-fashioned
home cooking
oh it's so good you guys
and to think
that we now know a cedarus family recipe
just makes me so happy
you guys could we
i would just give anything to do this
again well let's do it again i would
love it david i love you so much
it's so fun to share these like
bucket list
moments with you
um to know what that means but i missed
something
i honestly have
this is
i you guys have no idea how much you
mean to me although you might be getting
the impression
um we're going to have to adopt her oh
[Applause]
great i'll do it i have all the time in
the world uh don't forget to grab your
copy of carnival of snackery it is as
good
as it gets and when you have a high
standard like david sedaris is writing
you know what good is and it is that
good as usual so it's in stores right
now and amy sedaris my comedic female
and by the way
everybody be on amy's instagram if you
want a source of joy
like an iv in your arm amy sedaris
instagram i used to talk about accounts
i love of yours when like instagram
first started you've always followed me
too and i like that you posted the world
of interiors which is the only magazine
i get in the mail other
decorating magazines should be called
the world of inferiors because
are as good as world of interior that's
the best one i completely agree well we
can continue to bond on that
[Music]
you